what's going on guys this is rob and as
you guys know i am a big fan of the
wolverine comics when they're talking
about old school stuff because i'm an
old-school wolverine fan the new school
stuff isn't terrible it's just i'm kind
of a hipster in that way right
i feel a little dirty when i say that
but i'm kind of an old school fan in
that way so picking up here with
wolverine volume two uh technically
volume two is like issues eight through
twelve but they're two distinctly
different stories and so i'm really
calling issues eight through ten volume
2 and then 11 and 12 kind of wrap around
the first story dealing with the
vampires which uh which i'll call volume
three right we'll kind of call it a day
but the cool thing about this is that in
the the last video that we did we talked
about how wolverine kind of forged a
friendship with jeff bannister in the
sense that jeff bannister is a cia
operative and this was exceedingly
important right for a couple different
reasons one because of the fact that
wolverine's always been a guy who kind
of knows what people to network with
what people to hang out with and a lot
of that's just because of his history
his experience and two because regarding
krakowa one of the big things that we
know is that krakowa is not really on
the list of a lot of people in terms of
friends right the idea of mutants around
the world just consolidating into a
singular nation and the fact that kokoa
has really kind of propped itself up
under ultimatums and and kind of bribing
society to a degree right offering
medicines that only they can provide and
in a lot of ways undercutting a lot of
major corporations because politicians
are usually owned by major corporations
that in turn creates a scenario whereby
krakowa is now shunned by governments
because for the most part corporations
don't like them and for the most part a
giant nation of mutants really just
presents an existential threat to
humanity as a whole and so having
someone like jeff bannister on his side
is one of these instances where sure
there's the official communication
channels that kakoa has set up but
wolverine's got his own unofficial
channels the guys that can give him
information that maybe those official
channels for cocoa simply just can't do
and so what what kind of goes on is
there's a bit of a discussion in terms
of their own histories the kind of
mistakes they've made the kind of things
they've done because they both have a
pretty dark past in the case of jeff
bannister there was an instance when he
was new to being in the military right
he had just kind of enlisted and it was
one of those things where he had bought
into the propaganda right we as the us
military are the good guys whoever we
send you against are the bad guys and
that's it and their job was to take out
a convoy who of course they'd been told
were basically bad guys come to find out
what was actually going on is that in
the middle of this war what you had was
basically this convoy filled with
americans who were actually traveling to
the opposition to essentially end the
conflict and that jeff banister and his
guys being sent in to take out that
convoy was to ensure the war didn't end
that way the military industrial complex
could keep on going and so the result of
this is he's like you know we literally
kept the war machine going by killing
our own soldiers now i'm not in the u.s
military i don't really know if that
happens but a part of me has to believe
that it does and a part of me almost
kind of feels like it'd be naive to
believe that it doesn't happen but the
important thing here is that wolverine
asks him you know even after all that
you still work for the cie right you're
still a spook like if you're a cia spy
why are you still working for them
knowing all this is going on and the
response of jeff bannister is because
i'm trying to keep things like that from
happening again he can only do so much
but there is a bit of merit there now of
course he kind of has to work within the
lines right work within his his role his
place but having made contacts
networking different things like that it
allows him a kind of communication at
least a series of communication channels
that wouldn't be readily available to
him had he left the cia and so following
that he kind of asked wolverine what's
your whole story here and this is when
you start to get this kind of secret
history of wolverine and in fact we get
it on and off over the course of this
this story which is really really cool
but what this does is it actually picks
up with team x now those of you guys who
don't know about team x team x was
amazing so this was a concept that i
actually didn't become aware of until i
started reading x-men volume 2. once i
started going back and reading old
comics then i started learning more
about team x but at the time when i was
like 11 years old i didn't know that i
had to go and read other comics to
understand what was going on in the
comics that i was reading right then
right so the the long and short of this
with team x is this was initially the
entryway into the weapon x project not
conventionally what i mean here is that
team x was basically kind of like a
black ops wet work team that was an
extension of the cia but it was a
plausible deniability thing right like
if something happened to them if they
were caught then they would just be
totally disavowed by the cia they'd say
we have no knowledge of these guys as
far as we're aware they're mercenaries
working for some unnamed person out
there we have no idea what's going on
right it'd be able to be very easy for
the cia to just cut bait and bail right
as that was the whole role that team x
played now secretly and what team x
didn't know is they were actually an
extension of a kind of joint venture
between the united states cia and
canada's department h and so because
team x was so effective what had
happened is they were rolled into the
10th iteration of the 10th project of
weapons plus also known as weapon x and
that's why it is that wolverine's
healing factor was bonded to maverick
that's why sabertooth wolverine maverick
all these guys were basically brought in
and turned into what were basically the
weapon x project had their minds wiped
sent on missions different things like
that to a degree it's already kind of
happening it's just not something that
was made readily available until after
their tenure with team x but it's one of
these things where they talk about how
the kind of missions they've done and
the kind of things they've been engaged
in they had actually gone onto an oil
platform and basically took it out right
it was one of the biggest oil platforms
in the world and they did that because
of course that was their assignment
behind the scenes it was one corporation
paying to eliminate another corporation
and that was basically it but there were
thousands of people on this platform who
died but at the time he didn't really
care over the years as things have
changed and he's basically experienced
more and more stuff and kind of lived
more of a life he's come to terms with a
lot of these things that he did and
really gained a bit of that human side
but during these days of team x when his
mind was being wiped he was being used
as part of as part of weapon x honestly
that was never part of the equation
right his mind would be wiped he'd be
basically given a series of false
memories that would basically fall in
line with the mission that he was going
on to ensure its success because he
would have a personal stake in it and
then he would achieve his mission
everything would be done he'd go back
have his mind wiped again right it was
just part and parcel just kind of rinse
and repeat over and over and over again
and so what you actually end up finding
out here is that jeff banisher basically
tells him look i know you guys have a
lot of people out there that are gunning
for you but something you need to know
there's some group out there that calls
themselves the x desk and they're part
of the cia more so than that they're
behind the scenes of behind the scenes
in the cia right like most people in the
cia don't even know they're there the
fact that i was even able to get a name
is kind of astounding but they're
gunning for you we don't know what
they're gonna do we don't know what
their motivation is but the cia has it
out for the nation of cocoa and that
just makes good sense right the central
intelligence agency is ideally supposed
to deal with foreign threats while the
fbi and the nsa deal with domestic
threats but the important thing here is
that when it comes to the cia in terms
of how they view kakoa because gracoa
represents an existential threat to
humanity it would only make sense the
cia would create some kind of task force
that would serve the purpose of
monitoring the mutant population so what
you end up doing here is basically
switching to utah to what's only
basically described as some kind of us
government black site and you basically
got these guys that just kind of roll in
there they end up taking a handful of
these guys out and then in turn they
snatch up some dog tags one of which
belong to logan and then they basically
bail out after gaining some further
information and that's basically it
right we don't really know what their
motivation is we don't know what it is
they're specifically looking for we
simply just know that they're there but
whoever they are they were able to
overcome some pretty heavy hitters right
these guys are experts in stealth and
espionage the whole nine yards because
as most of you guys can probably imagine
breaking into a u.s government black
site and taking out everybody there and
then getting information and leaving
that's no small thing right that's a
little bigger than like stealing
information from facebook servers or
hacking twitch
it's kind of a big thing right and so
what we end up doing here is switching
to the point in krakow right now for
those of you guys who don't know the
point is kind of like the intelligence
hub right that's usually where sage
operates but if if cocoa had its own
like cia the point is where it would be
located what ends up happening here is
that with sage and beast calling
wolverine in that what we end up finding
out is that the nation of cocoa is
basically involved with this break-in
essentially at the u.s government black
site in utah and the reason why is that
while this would normally never involve
cocoa that what they did is they
attained blood samples and in fact they
were contacted by the cia to bring
somebody in and the reality of this is
the blood sample basically belongs or
seems to belong to agent zero also known
as david north also known as maverick
now maverick is a great character in all
honesty most modern day readers probably
won't care about christopher nord that's
one of the other names he uses he uses
all kinds of different aliases and even
by his own admission he doesn't really
know which name is his we know it's
christopher nord
but one of the things here is that he is
og right honestly if you really wanted
to get into maverick you'd have to go
and read some old x-men stuff right
really x-men volume 2 if you want like
the high octane fast-paced stories
involving team x but it's one of these
things where where christopher nord and
wolverine have a pretty sketchy history
together right i mean they were all part
of of weapons plus and uh and weapon x
right so they have that kind of history
there but more so than that they've kind
of been on-again off-again enemies for a
variety of different reasons but the big
question here is what's going on with
maverick and why would he orchestrate a
break-in into a cia black site and so
following that you switch over to la to
basically dazzler's house and what ends
up happening here is that as soon as all
these mercs basically break in of course
that's what they're being referred to as
the mercs once they break in there of
course they're met with the entirety of
hers her alarm system which is basically
just like these sonic dogs right just
emit like these crazy sounds that
basically almost shatter their eardrums
well rain shows up manages to get a hold
of one of these guys and then drags them
off and what you end up having here is
him basically interrogating it right he
realizes this guy's name is crosby and
that's when he asks the question what's
going on where's maverick because if you
guys are doing this maverick has to be
behind it he has to be the one
orchestrating all of this why is
maverick breaking in to government black
sites and stealing artifacts and things
like that that belong to the mutant
population what's the goal here and so
what you end up finding out is that in
the aftermath of the rise of krakowa
what you ended up getting is a giant
kind of ramping down of the
military-industrial complex as opposed
to years past and the reason why is
because in the aftermath of kokoa rising
suddenly these conflicts between the
united states and the middle east or
these conflicts between north and south
korea or things like that started
becoming less and less important because
again the rise of the mutant population
under the banner of a singular nation
represented an existential threat to the
entirety of humanity so while i wouldn't
say this is some kind of star trek-esque
situation where war disease and famine
are all basically gone and humanity's
been united in a way that was never
thought possible while that's certainly
not the case and that never will be in
mobile comics or here in the real world
what is going on here is even if only
momentarily a lot of humanity are
ramping back their their spending on
conflicts and amping up their spending
on intelligence all because they want to
know what's going on in krakowa that's
how big of an issue krakowa is and
that's what this guy says that with the
military industrial complex ramping down
and a lot of conflicts coming to an end
there really wasn't a whole lot of a
whole lot to do out there when it came
to these these soldiers right that for
one reason or another everybody was
either bored and hungry for action or
they were dissatisfied with how they
were treated and thought they'd be
better off in the private sector and so
while this guy kind of reveals a little
bit of this information and says like
all we know is that we're carrying out
jobs for a place called legacy house we
don't really know what's going on there
all we know is we've been contracted for
that like we're mercenaries we're paid
to perform tasks that require military
action before he can really divulge any
action or any information this guy's
shot in the head taken out just like
that and so what it does is it switches
over to wolverine basically being
dressed up by sage and beast and being
sent to madrapore now here's the thing
about madrid for we've talked about
madrid before i love this place nobody
knows how to navigate magiport better
than wolverine this guy's best suited
for it he's spent so much time in this
place but magipore is one of those
places where everybody minds their own
business right imagine when you're in
madrapor you follow a very specific rule
you didn't see anything because you
weren't there and if you were there well
you still didn't see anything because
you were asleep everybody minds their
business everybody just kind of does
their own thing no one snitches or rats
on anybody else it's very much a lawless
place and so when he gets to legacy
house of course he says i'm looking for
some company kind of goes through the
normal routine that you go through in
magic for because even in madrid itself
there is a kind of custom right a sort
of decorum that has to be abided by when
it comes to stuff because there are some
things that go on here even for magipore
are pretty shady and so what he says is
like i'm i'm actually looking for for
room 13. that's where i hear all the
action is right that's what she says
like four hundred thousand you know
currency for madrid bot is basically
what you got to pay to get into room 13
and that's where an auction is being
held and so what you end up finding out
as this auction goes on is wolverine
sort of muses about his own life on his
way there he talks about the time when
everything began to change for him and
there was a point where they ended up
taking out or going on this mission and
that they were you know essentially
killing all these people but unlike
wolverine or mavic or anybody else on
team x victor creed relished what it was
that he was doing the idea of wolverine
was we just need to take these targets
out we don't really need to torture them
or anything like that for victor creed
that was part of the fun he loved
engaging in torture he loved engaging
and and just kind of you know screwing
people up in the most physical ways
possible now this is something that we'd
already kind of known from wolverine's
history whether you go and you read
x-men volume 2 or you go back and you
read some of the early stuff that kind
of mentions team x to a degree what
little tidbits that you do get in the
early history of wolverine but one of
the big things that led to wolverine
leaving in those comics and it's kind of
being rehashed here is that this is
where things changed because he stopped
seeing himself as somebody who was a
weapon somebody who was basically a tool
to be used to achieve a goal and started
seeing himself as somebody that hey like
we have like we're people right we have
hearts minds souls all kind of stuff you
know we're not just here to torture and
inflict as much harm as we possibly can
and so following that that's really what
sort of led into the early defection of
wolverine involving team x when you
looked at guys like mastodon and so on
and so forth him basically leaving in
and kind of bailing out that's what led
really sort of began all this stuff now
again this is what really also went into
wolverine and the rest of the team being
snatched up and thrown into weapon x and
then basically going forward as weapon x
team members and then wolverine
ultimately escaping after having
adamantium bonded to his body and all
that kind of good stuff you guys pretty
much know all that history there but
it's a really cool and really insightful
thing for him and so once he actually
gets into this place once he gets into
the the actual auction room itself
something i want you guys to notice
everybody's here right you got members
of the right who are staunchly
anti-mutant right just like ultra
right-wing conservative crazy guys
you've got the kingpin you've got the
virundi right so the remade version of
the hellfire club you got all kinds of
people here and that's the nature of
magiport one of the things that also
goes on is that when it comes to the
legacy house auctions it's not
necessarily what you would expect it's
not really always this thing of hey guys
we capture deadpool we're going to
auction him off or it's not really like
hey guys we have a sample of wolverine's
healing factor so we're going to auction
that off or we're going to auction off
some vibranium from wakanda it's not
always that way instead a lot of times
it's just artifacts history so there are
people who were here as much for just
the historical value of the things they
can buy as they're here for actual
worthwhile things that can be weaponized
and used for various campaigns that they
have going on it's an awesome concept
and so once the whole thing kicks off we
get a really good idea of what this
auction house looks like when you find
out that one you've got a cyanide tooth
that belonged to black widow at one
point in time a prison painting made by
jigsaw of course he's one of the most
notable if not the most notable villains
of a frank castle you've got a goblin
glider that belonged to the green goblin
that was taken at some point the cowl of
captain america which he had when he was
thought out in avengers number four and
then release of course he switched his
outfit later on this original one is the
one that he was wearing when he was
initially frozen at the end of world war
ii the gloves of magnetic man the
gravestone of spider-man when peter
parker basically died and then also he
basically reveals that one of the big
things they have here is the severed
hand of wolverine now this throws
wolverine for a loop right because the
first question he asks here is how in
the hell do they get a severed hand from
me my hand's right here and so
immediately this starts to hit to the
idea that there might be some kind of
irregularity with the resurrection
protocols that some event took place
where wolverine's hand was basically
removed he ended up losing it he was
resurrected and then that portion of his
memory was removed so that basically
gracoa is in some ways doing exactly
what weapon x did which is modifying the
memory of wolverine and if that's true
that totally destroys any trust
wolverine would have for kakoa he would
likely bail out and start doing his own
thing that's one thing to know is that
wolverine's trust and his loyalty to
people always walks the knife's edge the
smallest slight the smallest betrayal
and he's gone forever you'll probably
never see him again not only that he's
actually given a tissue by the kingpin
to kind of you know wipe his hands and
kind of keep himself cleaned up a little
bit and of course drops it on the ground
and somebody picks it up they sort of
carry it away and so from there this
auction guy basically says like look
like the big thing that we have here is
maverick right this mutant known as
maverick now under any normal
circumstance this wouldn't matter right
i mean maverick is cool he's capable i
mean he's got some margin of a healing
factor it's nowhere near wolverines but
it's still relatively capable he can
absorb kinetic energy turn it into
concussive energy i mean the guy is
great in terms of being like an assassin
or something like that the real kicker
here and the reason why he's auctioning
for such a high number right like 150
million dollars so on and so forth is
because he's a mutant and so having
maverick on your side basically gives
you the keys to the kingdom maverick can
pass through cocoon gates and so in
effect you could have your own spy he's
been totally mind wiped right so he has
no knowledge of his own history or
anything like that but whoever it is
that wins the auction would basically
get their hands on maverick they could
use him and say go into krakow stay
there for a few months and then report
back and tell me what's going on this is
huge because you would have you have a
lot of people who are going to be
competing for this not just criminals
not just kingpin or somebody like that
entire nations would be vying for
something like this and so what you end
up finding out is that with this tissue
having been picked up and it basically
being analyzed they end up discovering
that it's actually wolverine and that's
when basically this information is just
kind of blown out all over the place
they're like hey guys so wolverine's
here uh he's part of the auction now
right everybody get him and of course
these numbers skyrocket 300 million
dollars and and so on and so forth right
it's insane the gloves of magnetic man
are used by the auctioneer to basically
ensnare wolverine because again his
bones are made of adamantium or at least
laced in adamantium and then following
that you kind of have this brief little
memory where maverick had basically
rescued wolverine or at least helped
wolverine in the midst of all this
following the events of his involvement
in weapon x and one of the things he
says is he says listen to me carefully
today is a victory over yourself of
yesterday and he keeps just he just
keeps telling him that right these two
are sitting in these cells as part of
weapon x he keeps telling him that right
like today is a victory over yourself of
yesterday kind of helping to remind him
this is important because what this does
is it ties into the idea this is one of
the reasons why wolverine was able to
escape his confinement during weapon x
is that where his mind was being wiped
so he was always reminding himself of
who he really was that he was not some
kind of an agent for weapon x that he
could find a way to break out to escape
that kind of a thing and so that's what
he keeps telling maverick and it's
enough for maverick to basically regain
his bearings and then all hell pops off
right all hell breaks loose like
literally wolverine and maverick are
just like let's get out of here man so
like they start shooting the place up
right i mean they just start like
shooting the whole place up the
auctioneer pulls out a handgun that
belonged to frank castle at one point
shoots maverick across the face but it's
not enough to actually you know kill him
it's just enough to injure him and he's
like hey man i'll take that injury dude
the injuries help
and so these guys just basically start
killing everybody like henchmen are
coming in left and right and they're
just slashing people all over the place
right just tearing these guys bit by bit
and the middle of it all you end up
having this woman who was previously
watching the conversation between jeff
bannister and wolverine and basically
says okay cool she takes the hand of
wolverine and then sends in all these
these uh cia operatives and then of
course you find out her name is special
agent ramirez and basically their job is
to take down wolverine and maverick now
the whole thing behind this is these
guys already right when you're talking
about regular foot soldiers in madrid
it's guys with guns right there really
isn't a whole lot doing there but when
you're talking about ci8 operatives who
are part of the x desk who are
specifically tasked with taking down
mutants they're more than enough to
contend with and that's why you
basically at this point have maverick
and wolverine who just bail out as fast
as they possibly can and get out of
there where they can and by this point
they're just running through magipore
and just fleeing for their life shooting
back at those guys those guys are
shooting back at them and again just
like you always expect in madrapor
everybody's minding their own business
right it's it's it is it is a place
where you can do what you need to do
without having to worry about people
snitch on you right so just because of
the fact that if you're discovered to be
a signature mad reporter they'll kill
you right they'll probably torture you
first and then they'll kill you right
just throw you into the ocean or
something along those lines but of
course this basically leads to maverick
having his own merc's crew basically
rescue him and wolverine and of course
they escape all the while a special
agent ramirez is just watching this
whole thing go down so once they end up
escaping it's a kind of a cool little
situation wolverine is very much at home
here with these mercs it's very
reminiscent to his days in team x and
his days during weapon x when it was him
and maverick and so on and so forth
there was a kind of bond a sort of
camaraderie almost like a brotherhood of
sorts that was formed there if for no
other reason than all the missions they
went on and all the things they did
together and so where initially
wolverine's very very hesitant to be a
part of the mercs he's kind of told by
maverick look you can join us and he
kind of starts entertaining the
possibility a little bit now ultimately
they end up traveling to what's
basically the safe house for uh for
legacy house which is where like all
these artifacts belonging to the mutant
population and it's not even just them
right it's the x-men it's advanced idea
mechanics hydra the fantastic four
shield the whole nine yards right all
these things that have just been taken
over the years whether it's because of
conflicts that unfolded because they
just sort of keep them around whatever
the case is right things they just kind
of snatched up they were just sort of
laying there after the end of a massive
event they're all taken and they're all
auctioned off to people for a variety of
reasons but all of it's basically
torched all of it's essentially
destroyed and so again at that point you
end up having wolverine who brings
maverick to krakowa and that's when he
kind of shows him what krakow is like
the reality of this is that maverick's
not comfortable here one of the things
to know is that mavericks sort of
continued on where wolverine stopped
that when wolverine kind of found a home
among the x-men back in giant-size x-men
number one when he joined the x-men team
that never really happened with maverick
maverick always kind of stayed on his
own he always did his own thing and
that's what he tells wolf reign like
look man you know i'm not really down
with this you know when wolverine says
like look we can remake you right we can
well i mean basically you have to kill
yourself but like the five can resurrect
you
and they can make you maverick like you
used to be the response of maverick is
no like if if the last few days have
taught you anything it's like i don't
want to go digging around in the past
who i am now is who i am and i'm fine
with who i am i'm fine with my mercs i'm
fine being where i am they're not really
family right it's not not a thing where
like he'll go to the ends of the earth
for his mercs at the end of the day he's
paying them for a job and if they die
he'll replace them with more that's just
kind of how he sees things at the end of
the day when it comes to maverick it's
just maverick right everywhere he goes
there he is he's really the only one he
actually really ever cares about and so
when he kind of extends this to
wolverine he's like look man i've got
everything i need right i've got
everything i need with my mercs or with
my my organization my business my whole
nine yards if you ever want to come join
the mercs hit me up right and that's
when wolverine says well if you ever
change your mind come and find me so the
door is kind of always open right the
offer is always there and so what you
end up doing is switching over to new
york when you have maverick showing up
at a coffee shop and sitting down with
special agent ramirez and what basically
seems to be going on here is that
because maverick is a mercenary and that
means his loyalties are to whoever it is
is paying him the most because special
agent ramirez seems to be paying him a
whole bunch of money or possibly because
of the fact that he's always been an
agent for special agent ramirez and
maybe it's one of these things where
this whole situation was set up for no
reason than to gain the trust of
wolverine again and then find a way into
kakoa so he can report back that
basically he's working with the cia
whether or not he's going to spill the
goods on krakowa to kind of serve as a
spy in krakowa and report back to the
cia on everything that's going on we
don't know but what it looks like here
is there's a wolf in the hinthouse
that's really what it looks like
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this to an end thank you
guys for watching and i will catch you
all later
peace